matthew mcconaughey mcdonough comment on
dit merci donc matthew mcconaughey
il vient du texas son mot préféré c et
c'est en 93 que le monde découvre son
accent iron mais très rapidement il
séduit les plus grands real même silbert
pour amistad avant de perdre toute
crédibilité dans des rôles de playboy
dénudées heureusement le texan est
résistant et dès 2009
que ce soit au ciné ou pour la télé il
rechausse les santiag direction son sud
natal
le résultat un oscar désormais à
hollywood
même les plus grands veulent imiter mais
après avoir côtoyé les étoiles matthew
semble avoir du mal à revenir sur terre
et depuis 2014 enchaîne les échecs
donc terminer matthew mcconaughey
alors qu'il est à l'affiché de the beach
boys le nouveau film d'harmony korine
tout juste sorti aux états unis chicza
essaye d'y voir plus clair sur le plan
de carrière le plus mystique de
l'univers
[Musique]
pour matthew mcconaughey fils de
pompiste et d'institutrices tout
commence à 24 ans par un casting celui
pour le rôle de woods orson dans
génération rebelle
[Musique]
une attitude décontractée
une gueule et surtout un accent bien de
chez lui qui permet à l'acteur de
s'offrir aux etats unis une popularité
instantanée
ça fait quinze années 90 il n'y a pas de
massilia ya brad pitt et george clooney
qui vient un peu après ses envies et à
johnny depp mais n'y en a pas beaucoup
elles sont où mais carey qui a aussi ses
valeurs si on veut du sud le sud ce sera
d'ailleurs le décor de son premier grand
rôle chez joël schumaker lorsqu'il
incarne en 96 un avocat sur fond de
luttes raciale mais sur la première
décennie des années 2000 mâconnais et
change de registre et se spécialise dans
la comédie romantique dont il devient un
pilier
moi
[Musique]
il fait alors craqué jennifer lopez dans
un mariage trop parfait
sarah jessica parker dans playboy à
saisir ou encore kate hudson deux fois
on avait l'impression qu'ils ont
incarnés c'était toujours la même chose
ils et elles at on soutenu avec une
belle femme en la blague était que dans
son contrat il fallait qu'il ya au moins
deux cents une scène avec ma tête me
connaître son nul parce que il est très
bon quoi une clause plutôt bien
respectée dans l'amour de l'or
[Musique]
là c'est de passer pour un cliché
l'acteur siffle lui même la fin de la
récré en 2009
[Musique]
en tout la pause durera deux ans gains
élevés
puis le téléphone se remet à sonner au
bout du fil c'est soderbergh qui avec
magic mike amorce le virage film
d'auteur de l'acteur
c'est le début de ce qu'on appelle à
hollywood la mac connaissance mélange de
mâconnais et de renaissance qui se
traduit d'abord par un retour aux
sources
en fait ils jouent beaucoup plus nuit
même en tenir il peut parler avec son
accent et peut être leur carnet
peut-être un peu plus sombre mais il
reste quand même le seul personnage de
texas donc mais aussi par une
métamorphose physique dans un 2010 elle
fait plutôt la mine de ce corps elle ça
joue beaucoup dans le film en fait c'est
quand un peu usé un peu fatigué elles
sont ou qui a perdu là le muscle crois
qu'on va en vrai avant croire et avec 20
kilos en moins là ma connaissance pro
fin avec un oscar pour son rôle choc de
cowboy atteints du sida dans dallas
buyers club du parc et demi à ne pas
glisser un gardien
acclamé par le métier
l'année d'après c'est le public cette
fois que le cow boy séduit avec
interstellar le blockbuster de
christopher nolan
et tu as
[Musique]
avec plus de 650 millions de dollars de
recettes ils s'offrent le plus gros des
collages au box office de sa vie mais
problème alors qu'il a le monde à ses
pieds le texan semble être resté coincé
en orbite
la preuve au lieu de transformer l'essai
il choisit de revenir avec des pubs de
voitures certes signe windings refn mais
tellement lunaire qu'elles deviennent
carrément des mêmes un make-up xtb
josh willingham
[Musique]
eco dessiner entre un soldat déserteur
au 19e siècle
un chercheur d'or dégarni un sorcier
malveillants
un flic annulé ou encore un capitaine de
bateau de pêche aux côtés d'anne
hathaway dans serenity matthew enchaîne
les bides et s'attire les foudres de la
critique
et c'est vrai qu'il a pas peur d'aller
très loin d'andy dans le film qui sent
qu'ils ont considéré comme très mauvaise
rennais si c'était le film a raté mais
détruit par la critique
donc il n'a pas peur d'aller vers la
réduction peut dire chaque fois et
aujourd'hui pour se remettre en selle
l'acteur se tourne à nouveau vers le
cinéma d'auteur avec the beach boys une
sorte de big lebowski sous acide signé
harmony korine bon après un premier
week-end d'exploitation outre atlantique
ça sent pas très très bon pitch d'hommes
le flop
voilà pour matthew mcconaughey qui a
crevé l'écran en mec défoncer la boucle
est bouclée
mais à bientôt 50 ans il serait
peut-être temps de refaire le coup de la
ma connaissance